David what do you think will happen when
Donald Trump is no longer president
whenever that is and he loses
presidential immunity from prosecution
so I'll answer the question remember
this whole idea of immunity it's not
been tested it really is more of a memo
that the Justice Department has put out
saying we as a policy don't believe in
in indicted or prosecuting a sitting
president but here's the way that I
imagine it will go if you were waiting
around imagining that Donald Trump is
going to be criminally charged and perp
walked and tried and potentially face
time in prison forget it forget it
I mean we you know it just doesn't
happen to presidents Trump has violated
the emoluments clause all sorts of
different financial crime I get it but
if you're waiting for the perp walk I
would not hold my breath let's just
remove Trump in November the country and
the world will be much better for it now
that being said there are active pending
criminal investigations in the Southern
District of New York the New York
Attorney General
there is almost no doubt whatsoever that
whenever Trump's national nightmare is
over and the mango menace is gone could
be in a few months could be in four
months and a year for years and a few
months rather his businesses are very
likely to be charged with all sorts of
criminal violations for financial
improprieties I don't imagine that
Donald Trump is actually going to take
the fall or be the one who gets charged
and certainly not convicted there are
likely going to be underlings that will
get plea deals who knows Trump is not
going to be convicted I would be shocked
if he is even charged in those financial
crimes it's going to be financial
irregularities could be anything from
money laundering misappropriation of
funds all sorts of stuff like that
now once Trump is gone he can be charged
with whatever a prosecutor wants to
charge him with but there's another
element in this it's not just the
general reality that presidents don't
get criminally charged once they leave
office how do you get a jury that any
legal system would say is a fair one
you can't ask for a change of venue
because it was the President of the
United States
you either have people who voted for the
guy on the jury who are not going to be
impartial jurors you have people who
actively disliked the guy who are not
going to be impartial jurors and even if
you and I can imagine a sort of a
political person that says listen I
didn't vote either way and I don't
really pay attention to politics how do
you actually get a an unimportant peers
in general as a president but
particularly when he is as polarizing as
Donald Trump has been so I don't mean to
say that this suggests Trump has not
committed crimes I don't mean to say
that Donald Trump should not be
prosecuted when he's gone but what I am
Telling You is the perp walk is not
happening the best we can hope for is
that there are some financial crimes
with which Trump's businesses are
charged and maybe somebody will take a
hit we don't really know today's program
is sponsored in part by the galaxies
series which is a series of three books
written by a really great author I
thought and I would call the genre sort
of political science fiction I've really
enjoyed the books it looks at the future
it explores what could happen to Planet
Earth if we stay on our path
environmentally it deals with space
travel it takes a sort of deep dive into
political psychology and it's a really
intriguing sort of dystopian look at the
future the stories are told from a
perspective that I think people in the
audience would really appreciate and
there's a ton of really excellent
artwork also that accompanies the books
I read a lot of books in this genre and
I'll tell you these books are very well
written the plot the characters are
compelling if you're someone who likes
politics and sci-fi you'll really like
these books again it's the Galaxy series
check it out for yourself for a limited
time we have a special deal set up where
my audience can get each book for just
99 cents go to david pakman.com slash
galaxy